what do you think uh is the connection
john between this ego pride thing
martial arts and actual violence in our
with our ancestors do you think
you ever plug into that you think
there's echoes of something going on
there or like you mentioned you have
flaws and demons
is it
deep in there somewhere do you think
we're struggling with those demons
yeah uh you'll need to patch up your
question a little bit though it's going
in several different directions wow that
was
not only am i being dominating jiu jitsu
i mean dominating interviewing no no no
no no no
uh
like okay now we interview you yeah but
you you went down the
evolution mean do you think
do you um
i don't mean just the line between what
is what is martial arts and what is
violence i mean there there seems to be
a gray area
that connects us to the the evolutionary
ancestors absolutely yeah yeah i mean i
i think there's a deep
recognition in all of us
that
um and this is
the evidence for this is is so easy to
uh to see in in daily life um
if you're walking down the street
and suddenly you hear a commotion and
two people are fighting
you will see
literally everyone on that street stop
whatever they're doing and watch the
fight
humans
are fascinated
by violence
and you've got to ask yourself why and
of course it's a recognition
that
for a significant part of our
evolutionary history
violence was one of the most important
elements in human existence
as much as we curse it as much as we
talk badly of it um
the juxtaposition between humans social
nature and their their need to for each
other to get along and to express
love amongst the
the various members of a given community
there are
disputes between humans that can't be
resolved and ultimately
throughout history violence has been the
number one method of
conflict resolution
um
for better or for worse and there's a
recognition in all of us that
this is where we come from
and there's a reason why
combat sports have this
thing where
people will watch them and they might
even be repulsed by them but they find
it difficult to take their eyes from it
and
[Music]
i do believe that most combat athletes
carry that sense
of their
even if it's on a subconscious level
this kind of
belief that
this is who we are um george you use the
word pride and i believe that's a big
part of it i believe that
um
most humans have this sense of
self-worth and pride which they're
willing to fight for
and uh if it gets crossed by someone
else they're willing to stand that
some people will stand more early and
some people could be pushed further back
but everyone's got that line beyond
which they won't be pushed
and there's some kind of deep
recognition in all of us that we have
that somewhere within us no matter how
hard we try to bury it or what have you
and that's why i believe there will
always be this eternal
interest in combat sports
now
i don't believe that most people today
have any kind of respect for
unrestricted violence or
non-consensual violence
um i think most people most good people
are repulsed by that now i'm
i'm sure that as humanity
improves out into the future that will
become more and more widespread
but
that's not to say we we can't exercise
these these
old evolutionary demons inside of us and
um
uh
and
sometimes there are just disputes
between different people different
cultures different nations where
ultimately it's going to come to
enter into a shoving match and that will
degenerate further into violence there's
always going to be
a need for humans to be able to
to uh
express themselves
through violent methods and to use
physical force to get to their their
goals and objectives
our
our need as humans is always to find a
balance between the two forces of
conflict and cooperation
we need cooperation because humans
isolated from each other
more or less helpless and useless
in order to
advance human communities need to build
and grow
and so that sense of cooperation occurs
in most of our daily lives
but there will also be irresolvable
conflicts where physical force has to be
used to form a resolution and so most
human beings find themselves
swinging like a pendulum between
conflict and cooperation
and
and that is something which
really gives birth i think to combat
sports